hi everyone my name is erila i
am here with quick take and today is
black women's equal pay day
it's also black national business month
and it's a great overlap we are joined
by a very special guest
but before we get started in case you
don't know what black women's equal pay
day is it is the day that essentially
marks
the time it takes on average for black
women to earn as much as their white
male counterparts in the workplace for
2019.
so for black women on average that is
220
extra days of work now we're joined
today
by menda hearts she is a best-selling
author of
the memo she is also a professor and an
entrepreneur and she
has more than this world's experience in
in negotiating her worth and getting
what is hers when it comes to equal pay
so thank you so much for joining us
today linda
thank you for having me excited to be
here to have this important conversation
very important we appreciate your time
so we just want to hop right in
um black women's equal pay day has
really been picking up steam
on social media and just like in general
conversations
um over the past couple years what is
the buzz and why is this holiday so
important
yeah you know it's interesting i'm i
remember when there wasn't a highlight
for black women in our equal
and equal pay day and so even though
this is not a celebratory time
uh it is an aware a time for awareness
and so i want to really
um highlight that that you know there
are pay inequities even within women
uh as it pertains to women so white
women make around 80 cents and asian
women make around
90 cents on the dollar to a white man
and then
black women 62 cents and you think about
uh we're there but then trans women
latinx women and indigenous women they
make even less so it's really important
that we talk about the
disparities even within women right
right so tell us about your experience
um with equal pay and how you've been
able to kind of combat
the inequities you know one of the
things
is educating myself and talking with
other women and so i know growing up
sometimes in a black family we have been
told you know don't tell anybody your
business don't talk about money
and sometimes we have to um talk to
people about money people that you trust
or people that you know so that you can
get the most information so for example
um i remember hearing i was at an event
i heard a woman say
oh women make 79 cents on a dollar
and i thought oh that's interesting and
then i went to further investigate and
then i realized that black women weren't
making that
and so i i would have never known that
had not been talking about what they
make and so
um even now as an entrepreneur and a
public speaker there are
times when i have to talk with other
women and say hey i know that you spoke
here
two weeks ago what did they offer you
right and i've been in a situation where
i've been offered one amount
and another woman who happens to be
white um
we talk and we have a conversation and i
find out that she got paid three times
more than i did
to do you know we're both authors and um
so it's one of those things that once
you gather the information you gotta
advocate for yourself
wow so let's talk a little bit about
like where does this
where do these inequities stem from like
what is the logic behind it because
um there were there has been reports
about how black women are the most
educated
um racial group like in the country with
most amount of undergraduate and
post-secondary degrees and i'm just
wondering where does that discrepancy
where does that discrepancy stem from
we're super educated yet we're underpaid
why is that yeah well it's a systemic
issue
one of the things it's also an
opportunity gap i think
it makes no sense that black women are
one of the most educated groups in the
country and yet when you look at the
c-suite and most corporations are
non-profit we represent one percent
of the c-suite and so we're doing
everything that we've been told
gets us ahead right and yet so we really
need our allies and our leaders to
lean into their courage and provide
opportunities so that we can have
our seat at the table and it's the
reason why i wrote the memo because we
talk about women in the workplace
but we don't always focus on the
differences so
black women experience the workplace
different than other women and so
um we have to shine the light on the
facts so that we can find solutions and
i'm really excited about this
opportunity to
um you know a lot of companies are
making commitments to black employees
right now and i think one of the ways
they can help us solve this problem is
by doing um
a pay audit and being transparent about
their pay similar to like companies like
salesforce you know be transparent
and then we can talk about solutions
definitely so in terms of solutions what
i know you mentioned in your book that
it's really and you just kind of touched
on it now but it's really important to
share salaries um amongst women like
what are the actual benefits and how can
that like amount to some sort of change
yeah i think it's really important
because if we're operating in a silo
you're never going to know
what's possible for you right or maybe
you can encourage another woman and i
think that we really have to talk about
it
out loud uh and even in our friend
circle so that we can
understand what we might be missing out
on and so part of the equation that i
talk about is yes
as women we can ask more right so what's
the part of the equation that we can
solve
that's making sure that if we need a
negotiation coach we hire one
right we look at uh our state's um
equal pay laws right making sure that we
have all the necessary information
in our toolkit but on the other side we
have to ask
you know it does show that sometimes
we're just not asking
and that's not the whole problem but you
know we we can't close the gap if we
don't ask and
and also too the other part of it is if
your company is not
valuing you in pay then you also have to
strategize well maybe this isn't the
right table for me so i think there
as women of color as black women we have
so much power um
and we just have to flex that but then
also we have to have companies that are
invested in our success
so let's say hypothetically we
i have a conversation with some friends
and i find out that i'm making a lot
less like what
what are the do's and don'ts like how do
you move forward in that situation
without
you know potentially risking your
financial stability
yeah that's a really great um point and
i'm not saying you know
bust in your you know manager's virtual
door and say you know you better have my
money right now you know
that's not the way to go about it um i
would say definitely through strategy i
have a whole chapter
dedicated to negotiation and strategy
but one of the things that we can do
again if you don't feel comfortable um
negotiating
then practice role play you know so
while you're asking one of your friends
at brunch you know what are you making
you know say hey would you role play
with me i want to um discuss various
scenarios
that could be the potential outcome
right so if my manager says
no what do you do you don't just say
okay and walk away but say well
um what would make it a yes you know
what do i need to do in the next three
to six months to make that possible
right and so i think that we need to
also don't just put it out there but
also
make sure that you're getting the
answers that you need but um
additionally i think we have to keep
having these conversations because again
we're never going to know
we would never know that asian women
were making 90 cents on a dollar
if we weren't talking about it right and
so we have to get comfortable and be
vulnerable
uh with people that you trust and again
even in my own life recently
i've had to talk about my salary
um with other women so that i got the
information that i needed right
and and in that situation i just want to
tell you it can be
stressful right it can be scary but we
need to lean into our courage because we
will never benefit when we're cautious
nice and when it comes to that
i'm wondering we are in the middle of
you know one of the worst pandemics
we've had in a century
and we know that black women tend to be
breadwinners for their families
how is the pay gap kind of hindering the
ability to
build wealth and kind of um curb
intergenerational struggles
yeah i'm glad you bring that up because
i mean that's a huge pain point
for us because you know we're making
those 62 cents on a dollar it and
and that's on the high end right you
know for some people aren't even making
that as black women and so
um we have to be under uh mindful of
that but then many of us
because we are the first person in our
family to graduate from college
we hold the brunt of making sure that
everyone else is doing okay right so
maybe now we have relatives that you
know are experiencing
layoffs or furloughs so we're the ones
that people look to
to to help out and so it's very hard for
us to build generational wealth when
we're stretched
thin and then the other part of that is
when we don't have the opportunities to
sit in the executive suite and we don't
get our pay
then that also impedes upon our chances
to have board seats
right and so that's another um if you
don't have the
if you're not in the c-suite then that
might not look at you as a
as a viable candidate to have an uh a
board seat on a publicly traded board
and so that's another
layer of closing the wealth gap and so
we're we don't we're missing out on a
lot of
opportunities to build wealth because we
don't have the opportunity
and the access and so i really would say
that this is where our leaders
and our managers really need to um think
about the role that they play
uh in this because we're doing all the
things that we're supposed to do
right and so there's still a disconnect
and it takes two to make a thing go
right
okay so it's real negotiation happens on
both sides definitely and speaking of
negotiations we have a really good
question
um from the audience is there a
difference between negotiating
advice for women black women of
different ages from you know maybe
early 40s to early 20s is there a
different
way to kind of go about that strategy
wise
yeah you know i think some of the tools
that we need in our toolkit i know for
me when i was in a corporate environment
the one thing that really helped me
when i was younger and when i was a
little more seasoned was getting a coach
getting a career coach
and they really helped me hone in on how
to tell my career story
and not just i want more money but how
do i articulate that story
and base it upon what the company's
bottom line is as well as my personal
career goals and so once you learn how
to tell your career story
and then also once you've had some
conversations with other people to see
what the range is
then you have some room to negotiate and
i also want to say that
negotiation isn't just about money but
it's also those friend benefits too
i've seen people negotiate working from
home right
i've seen people have professional
development stipends i've
seen people negotiate career coaches and
so dream a little bit bigger
as women and see and and don't count
yourself out because you feel maybe i'm
too
too old or too young um we need to close
this gap and it's going to take
all hands on deck definitely
so in your book um you mentioned that if
there's anything anyone should take away
it's just
knowing your sense of worth you know
sense of self and i'm just wondering if
you can kind of define what that should
look like when it comes to
the career landscape yeah i think
uh as black women in particular it can
be tough because we don't often see
ourselves at the highest levels of
leadership
right and so we're working very hard
we're asking for these things
and you know some of our environments
would say that we're not ready
or the narrative would be that you know
just wait your turn
and that can really cause us to
if we don't have a um a strong sense of
self it could really dictate
the things that we go after right or the
way we might shrink ourselves and so i
think it's really important to
you know one of my favorite quotes and
every time i get a chance to say it i
will
it's by audrey lord and she says beware
of feeling like you're not good enough
to deserve it and once we hone
into that uh we just have to go after it
we have to go for it
and so i i definitely want to encourage
um
you know all black women to to to ask
for more
essentially you know when i and again i
know it can be tough
um but it's one of those things where if
we don't do it who else will
right and and you got to know that um
you deserve more than enough you are
more than enough you worked really hard
to get here so none of this is charity
this is your right
uh to have equal pay for equal work and
um i just want to you know remind you to
be involved in different groups you know
surround yourself with the network that
can also encourage you on those moments
where you feel like
you know i just don't know if i can keep
moving writer i just don't know if i can
ask and so
just remind yourself i tell myself a new
story every day and it's i belong in
every room
i enter but not every room uh deserves
to have me in it right and so we have to
we have to take back that narrative uh
even if some of these
you know companies and institutions
would say otherwise
that brings up a really good point that
i've noticed in like my friend circles
and just other colleagues it's like
we know that companies for the most part
about their bottom line
what's going to work best for them why
do you think is that black women and
other women of color
tend to have these emotional
entanglements when it comes to
negotiating the salary like why are we
so
prone to lowballing ourselves yeah i
love that you use the word entanglement
um because i think that many of us are
really in these workplace entanglements
and i think that as women as black women
we've been loyal to a fault
right because we've been taught you know
just go in work hard keep your head down
if you work hard you're gonna get the
thing right and what we realize is
there's a system in place that doesn't
always reward
those who work the hardest and so i
think because we've been
conditioned to think that's how it works
that this is a meritocracy so it's hard
to unlearn
those things right and so we really have
to lean into that courage and
and ask for what we want and it's small
acts of courage right you know i can
talk to you about this now
but it took a lot to get to this point
right and i still
have to self-talk and have a growth
mindset to say
you know even when i say wow am i asking
for too much there is no too much
because the one thing i want to
stress is there's a range for a reason
right there's a
reason and most companies are going to
expect for you to negotiate in some way
shape or form
right so when you negotiate and they're
like oh well good
you know so so lean into it and do it
not just for you but do it for the
next generation of women of color
because the more we ask we can close
that gap for them
wow that's that's actually a really good
point i never realized
that the range was there for that reason
for negotiating
that's really good feedback um another
really good audience question
if you're familiar how does the us rank
against
other countries in paying black women
yeah you know i don't know the answer to
to that but i imagine i mean from
some of the women that have read the
memo and i hear from they say that hey
we experience the same inequalities
you know in uk and london in south
africa and so
i think globally this is an opportunity
for us to rise up together and say you
know
we're not giving companies we're not
giving anyone pass to pay us
uh unfairly right and so when we talk
about psychological safety part of
psychological safety
is being able to get paid fairly right
doing
work and getting paid comparably and so
i think that
if we want to create that for black
women in the workplace then we need to
look at
the salaries right so if
a woman say has been in the company for
two and a half three years
been busting their butt to you know
bend over backwards as you said you know
it's not always about
how hard you work i think it's it's a
thing of like us learning to work
smarter but let's say
we've been working really hard for a
long time and then it comes to a point
where you ask for a raise
and you don't get it what are what
should you consider
before potentially walking away like
what other things can you do
in that role if you really love it
before you say i've
given it my entirety and now i have to
go
um great question i think that part of
that is under
before you even go into the negotiation
you need to draw your lines in the sand
right you have to practice what are a
few different scenarios
if it's a yes great but if it's a no
then okay not right now
then when right so um go play with those
scenarios or write it down whatever
works best for you
but then understand what you're willing
what you're willing
to say yes to and no to because
oftentimes i think as women as black
women and
black women we center everybody else in
the workplace
and remember that we can also center
ourselves and we have careers
and we have goals and we have dreams so
we have to make sure that we're that
we're
positioning ourselves in the right way
and so the last thing that i'll say
is it's really important to um
push back a little bit right so again if
it's a no then
okay it's not right now but can we
revisit this conversation in three
months what do i need to do to get it to
a yes
and and the other thing two is even if
you don't get a yes don't be discouraged
uh because this is also this is good
information because if you're
if you've been somewhere for two years
they may not value you in the way
that you need them to and so then you
have some more information to say hey
do i want to stay here or do i want to
strategize my next move
and so we have more power than we think
so even we've all heard no
but um even with the memo i heard no
from four publishers but one said yes
right and so it's one of those things
where you know if not here then where
but don't don't you stop asking don't
you sleep don't you stop pushing
right and i'll end with this question
how could
america and just the economy benefit
from paying women
of all colors but especially black women
because it's black women's equal payday
how could they benefit from just paying
women what they're owed
or equally yeah yeah i think we just
overall psychologically safe environment
for everyone to thrive at work
you know you would never tell the
marketing department
go and do that campaign and pay them
half to get it done right
i mean it would just be absurd for you
to think that they can
pull this off without having some
investment and so i really want to push
back and say companies
show black women how you want to be
invested in their success and
you may not be able to hire you know 50
black women tomorrow and put them in the
c-suite but you can start paying them
fairly
yeah well i've learned so much i really
appreciate this is there anything else
you'd like to add
before we keep asking
even if it hurts keep asking
well thank you so much for joining us
menda
um i'm hoping that the next time we talk
it's about how
everyone is getting paid equally and
yeah keep on doing the good work
thank you appreciate your time